[Musique]
bonjour à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
sport etc ce mois-ci encore les
questions de société se sont invitées
dans le sport alors on va parler de
femmes de rugbyman abîmée et de
climatisation de retraite également
évidemment tout de suite le sommaire le
sport féminin tribuche sur la maternité
et la médiatisation quelle place pour
les femmes sur nos écrans et pour les
maires de famille dans les grandes
compétitions à six mois de la Coupe du
monde en France et en plein Tournois des
six nations le monde du rugby s'inquiète
de l'état de ces pratiquants des
amateurs aux professionnels le rugby
est-il aujourd'hui un sport dangereux il
y a un an la Russie déclaré la guerre à
l'Ukraine doit-on accueillir les
athlètes russes à Paris pour les jeux le
comité olympiques international il est
favorable mais la question est loin
d'être tranchée
pour m'accompagner aujourd'hui j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir Catherine bellriti
sénatrice les républicains de Moselle
bonjour j'aurais peut-être dû vous
présenter comme une ancienne karatéka de
haut niveau rapidement 7e dan double
championne du monde triple championne
d'Europe quadruple championne de France
j'ai juste tout à fait également à mes
côtés Jean-Baptiste Renner et dacteur en
chef à l'équipe bonjour Philippe
Spanghero ancien joueur de rugby et
fondateur de l'agence team one et
Florian Gazan éditorialiste bonjour
au début du mois l'art comme l'Autorité
de régulation de la communication
audiovisuelle et numérique à organiser
la traditionnelle semaine du sport
féminin alors où sont les femmes sur nos
écrans et parmi les dirigeants sportifs
c'est l'affiche de sport etc
[Musique]
je rappelais votre carrière sportive
est-ce que vous vous avez le sentiment
que vos performances étaient autant
considérées autant mis en valeur que
celle des hommes bon alors bien sûr bien
sûr que non
il est désolé bien sûr mais en plus dans
le karaté et bien on a surtout une
majorité d'hommes et dans la compétition
et bien forcément les femmes ont
toujours été moins bien reconnues mais
il y a eu une très belle évolution et
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on accorde
beaucoup plus d'importance également au
titre remporté par les femmes d'autant
plus que bien souvent beaucoup plus de
femmes ont apporté
c'est bien vrai mais alors on a encore
peut-être un peu de mal à donner aux
femmes la place qu'elle mérite donc dans
sport etc on a choisi pour commencer
cette émission de mettre en lumière la
femme qui dirige les championnats du
monde de ski alpin qui se déroule en ce
moment chez nous à Courchevel et Méribel
elle est triple médaillée olympique de
ski championne du monde de slalom
nous trouvons Perrine Pelen en direct de
Courchevel Perrine bonjour merci de nous
accorder un petit moment en au cœur de
ces championnats du monde qui sont
j'imagine qui se vivent sur une allure
frénétique nous posions la question de
l'exposition des sportifs et de leur
performance l'exposition dans les médias
et notamment cette exposition par
rapport à l'exposition que connaissent
et que dont jouissent les hommes vous
vous avez ressenti un traitement inégal
dans votre carrière c'était l'âge d'or
du ski français
alors écoutez dans le ski je dois dire
que j'ai en fait ma carrière est tombée
à un moment donné où les femmes les
dames et avaient plus le Ventoux nous
avions nous faisions des résultats voilà
plus performants que les hommes donc je
dois dire qu'on a été très bien servi
pendant toute une période avec Fabienne
serra avec Christelle Guignard
je dois dire qu'à aucun moment j'ai
considéré avoir souffert
d'un déficit de médiatisation par
rapport aux hommes et en témoigne aussi
la considération de la part de la
Fédération internationale qui
aujourd'hui
proposent les mêmes primes que ce soit
pour les garçons pour les dames
effectivement pendant ces championnats
du monde de ski est-ce que vous avez
constaté vous une différence je sais pas
dans le traitement entre les épreuves
masculines et féminines
écoutez de notre point de vue pas du
tout
si l'on considère les sites d'accueil
Méribel qui accueillent les dames
Méribel qui est qui accueille toutes les
épreuves féminines tandis que Courchevel
accueille les épreuves masculines
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que les
tribunes donc sont de même taille
en début de semaine il y a eu un petit
léger décalage entre les tribunes au
niveau des spectateurs grand public mais
là ce qu'on peut dire c'est que sur
toute la période au niveau des des
invités de tout le programme
d'hospitalité on a pu constater une
égalité de fréquentation et une ferveur
pour les dames aussi forte que pour les
garçons assurément est-ce que vous
faites juste nous préciser pourquoi
Courchevel et Méribel pourquoi les
hommes et les femmes sont séparés sur
ces championnats du monde
en fait ça a été un concept de
candidature qui est née à l'occasion des
finales de la Coupe du monde en 2015 et
qu'on s'est posé la question d'une
candidature France de pouvoir proposer
ces deux cousines puisqu'elles sont
d'une vallée elles sont situées à une
vallée des carres
15 minutes en voiture ou alors ces deux
remontées mécaniques à ski si on a le
loisir et le bonheur de pouvoir passer
d'une vallée à l'autre à ski on est au
cœur du domaine skiable des Trois
Vallées
et après qu'on s'est posé la question de
la répartition des épreuves la piste de
Courchevel est un peu plus exigeante
elle est plus raide beaucoup plus
soutenue elle est orientée en face nord
tandis que la piste de Méribel est en
plein soleil une piste qui est déjà bien
connue des dames puisque déjà haute des
épreuves féminines à l'occasion des Jeux
Olympiques d'Albertville et puis Méribel
avait aussi accueilli des coupes du
monde là mais les finales de la Coupe du
monde
vous êtes encore aujourd'hui la dernière
championne du monde française de slalom
vous étiez vous êtes donc à la tête de
ces championnats du monde de ski est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer comment
on passe de cette vie de championne à
cette vie de dirigeante
alors c'est une longue vie de dirigeante
puisque j'ai arrêté le ski à extrêmement
longtemps et j'ai démarré ma carrière
port poste sportif de haut niveau en
intégrant en fait le comité
d'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
d'Albertville c'était il y a 30 ans
voilà vous voyez à quel point j'ai
arrêté il y a longtemps j'ai toujours eu
à cœur je suis la 7e de 8 enfants de
pouvoir mener ce double parcours à la
fois de sportifs de haut niveau et puis
des études ce qui fait que pendant ma
carrière en fait j'ai un parcours
atypique déjà j'ai pu faire kiné en fait
d'accord mais à la fin de maquillage
sportive j'ai souhaité ajouter un
troisième cycle et j'ai intégré le
troisième cycle d'acc Lisa à l'époque ce
qui m'a permis de véritablement m'ouvrir
à nous de nouveaux univers et c'est sous
les conseils de Jean-Claude Killy à
l'époque j'ai intégré le service
marketing des Jeux Olympiques
d'Albertville et puis la maison de ces
grands événements des moyens de
promotion et de développement
touristiques pour la Savoie j'ai œuvré
pendant toute ma carrière à la fois avec
une dimension promotion touristique et
puis à la fois
organisatrice d'événements dans le
domaine de l'aviron permettant de mettre
un coup de projecteur bleu sur la Savoie
des lacs la Savoie d'été
des championnats du monde de canoë-kayak
également de handball ou encore bien sûr
nous avons accueilli les championnats du
monde de ski de Val d'Isère c'est la
dernière fois qu'ils avaient été
accueillis en Savoie c'était à
Val-d'Isère il y a 14 ans félicitations
en tout cas Perrine pour cette
organisation merci beaucoup d'avoir
passé un moment avec nous plus de femmes
parmi les dirigeants de sport cela
éviterait peut-être certains freins
violents que connaissent certaines
sportives dans leur carrière je pense
notamment à la navigatrice Clarisse
Kremer alors je rappelle rapidement ce
qui s'est passé elle a été laissée
hacker par son sponsor Banque Populaire
pour le prochain Vendée Globe raison
invoqué elle risquait de ne pas être
modifier du fait qu'elle n'a pas
participé à cette course et pour cause
elle est devenue maman au moins de
novembre dernier et Catherine balleretti
Clarisse Kremer est-ce que c'est quelque
part une punition pour avoir voulu
devenir maman et bien en quelque sorte
je pense que oui je trouve cela
extrêmement dommage et dommageable qu'on
ne lui ai pas fait confiance j'ai
moi-même été confronté à ce problème à
l'époque où moi aussi j'avais envie
d'être maman après mon premier titre de
championne du monde j'ai eu ma fille au
mois d'avril les compétitions les
championnats du monde se déroulaient en
novembre je n'avais pas fait toutes les
qualifications heureusement pour moi
mais mes entraîneurs et la Fédération
m'a fait confiance et j'ai remporté un
deuxième titre de championne championne
du monde en novembre oui parce que là en
fait elle aurait pu elle aurait pu se
qualifier Jean-Baptiste René et à ce
jour elle peut encore en fait parce
qu'il faut juste expliquer que la
qualification pour le Vendée Globe elle
se joue sur plusieurs courses et de
longs mois et jusque grosso modo jusqu'à
l'été 2024 elle peut encore accumuler
accumuler ce qu'on appelle des milles
c'est-à-dire que pour se qualifier et
être dans 40 bateaux qui ont le droit de
participer au Vendée Globe il faut faire
un maximum de 1000 donc mathématiquement
elle peut encore le faire c'est vrai que
son sponsor Banque Populaire à estimer
qu'il y avait un risque
étant donné qu'elle est son
indisponibilité pendant que plusieurs
mois elle pouvait ne pas accumuler assez
de 1000 mais elle peut encore le faire
c'est une situation comme très complexe
elle soulève beaucoup de questions mais
je pense que en fait c'est une
conjonction de plusieurs mauvais
facteurs en fait et notamment du
règlement du Vendée Globe qui impose
notamment ce nombre de mille et ne
prévoit pas des cas particuliers comme
celui de charisme mais justement est-ce
que cette mise en valeur c'est pas le
moment de changer quelque chose dans les
dans les règlements oui sans doute mais
pour le prochain Vendée Globe
malheureusement c'est très compliqué de
changer un règlement en cours de route
changer une qu'on peut le règlement une
compétition alors qu'elle a démarré
c'est compliqué parce que ça serait pas
juste si on si on décidait de dire bon
bah alors comme elle a comme elle est
tombée enceinte elle a eu un bébé elle a
d'office une place qualificative ils
envisagé de le principe de la de la
welcard qui pourquoi pas mais le truc
c'est qu'il y a quand même donc il y a
40 inscrit ça veut dire que si on enlève
un de ses 40 inscrits pour la faire
rentrer en welcard quelque part ça pose
une question non pas d'égalité mais
d'équité donc c'est un peu complique ou
alors on fait un 41e bateau mais dans
l'absolu il faudrait qu'elle puisse se
qualifier de la même manière moi je
trouve ça c'est un sujet qui est un peu
un peu sensible et je pense qu'il faut
il faut le prendre dans sa globalité pas
uniquement sous ce filtre à cet axe de
la maternité c'est un peu ironique et
c'est que même si le mot est pas très
bien choisi pour Clarisse Kleber c'est
que ça concerne la voile qui est un des
rares sports ou femmes et hommes partent
sur la même ligne sur mauvais jeu de
mots voilà donc je pense que les
navigateurs et les navigatrices ils ont
ils sont très attachés voilà il y a il y
a peut-être cette petite faille de
règlement ou peut-être c'est quelque
part c'est presque un cas particulier
c'est un cas quasiment unique une Banque
Populaire a beaucoup aidé les femmes
dans la voile et dans la course au large
effectivement et d'ailleurs il y a une
skippeuse qui s'appelle Jeanne Grégoire
qui est plus en activité aujourd'hui
mais qui a été dans ce cas là qui a eu
une maternité donc eu un enfant elle
s'est éloignée de son bateau pendant
quelques années et elle l'a retrouvé à
posteriori oui donc c'est un cas
particulier dans le rugby ça se passe
comment vous êtes les rugby woman je
sais pas si c'est comme ça qu'on dit son
protégés par la convention collective
nationale du sport qui qui implique le
maintien de salaire très peu d'abord
parce que dans le championnat les filles
sont pas professionnel encore donc il y
a que quelques joueuses concernées par
des contrats fédéraux pour qu'elle
puisse être plus performante avec
l'équipe de France à 7 ou à 15 mais dans
le rugby c'est pas tout à fait encore un
sujet qui est arrivé sur la table par
manque de moyens financiers par contre
moi ce que ce que je reproche à cette
situation convivi là et qui est revenu
fréquemment ces derniers temps dans le
sport professionnel féminin c'est le
manque d'anticipation
on a l'impression qu'on découvre que que
les femmes donc il doit y avoir quand
même il doit y avoir des choses dans les
contrats qui explicitent que une année
de maternité je pense que cette
navigatrice peut entendre
l'investissement financier de son
sponsor bien sûr et le risque de pas
avoir de bateau qui partent si les
choses sont précisées en amont on a vu
des histoires récemment dans le foot
professionnel notamment à l'OL de Miss
sous pression de filles qui ont voulu
prendre leur congé maternité avec des
menaces de pas renouveler leur contrats
etc ça ça peut plus exister il y a des
cas c'est particulier en plus on parle
de l'Olympique Lyonnais qui est quand
même le club en France qui a le plus
fait pour le pour le foot féminin il y a
eu cette joueuse Sarah bjorque qui s'est
exprimée sur les réseaux sociaux et qui
a rappelé que effectivement le l'OL
l'avait quelque part abandonné n'avait
pas maintenu son salaire alors que la
règle de la Fédération internationale de
football indien implique et oblige à se
maintient de salaire mais à chaque fois
c'est des cas c'est compliqué il faut
changer la loi et dire que les sportifs
sont des femmes à part et
je crois que ça serait dommage de passer
par la loi parce qu'il y a à chaque fois
qu'on veut imposer quelque chose
concernant les femmes il faut passer par
la loi je trouve ça un petit peu dommage
mais je pense qu'effectivement là on a
manqué d'anticipation il y a
effectivement le problème de ceux qui se
sont vraiment préparés en disant
pourquoi elle serait avantagé par
rapport à nous si c'est compliqué c'est
vrai que c'est une affaire assez
compliquée mais je crois que c'est au
fédération de s'organiser sur sur ses
compétitions et de faire en sorte que
les femmes soient reconnues bien
qu'elles veuille aussi à un moment donné
être mère et voilà tout ça ça s'organise
au niveau de la Fédération voilà
aujourd'hui il y a quasiment autant de
règles que tu fédérations en fait
la Ligue nationale de handball elle
prévoit 11 mois
mois de maintien de salaire la
Fédération française de football qui a
sans doute d'autres choses à faire en ce
moment mais en tout cas n'applique pas à
la lettre la consigne de la Fédération
internationale de football donc il y a
aussi parce que les fédérations ne sont
pas assez féminisées au niveau alors
certains ça c'est la question et là où
il y a une volonté il y a une semaine et
et one ça a été porté par la
vice-président de la fédération beaucoup
Béatrice Barbusse et par la présidente
de la Ligue Féminine notre Jimi Yaro et
elles ont Eugène de cause et elles sont
passées d'une période de trois mois
légale de de d'arrêt maladie lié à la
maternité même c'est le terme un peu
particulier mais c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelle à 12 mois et donc finalement
c'est vers ça qu'il faut tendre donc je
crois quand même qu'il y a un éveil des
consciences dans la volonté d'aller vers
là et aujourd'hui en plus pour cette
constater que dans le ça fonctionne donc
je crois qu'on n'est pas loin de la
vérité quand même et il y a aussi le cas
de ces sportifs qui sont qui dépendent
pas de d'une qui sont passés les
joueuses de tennis
qui a arrêté pour faire son bébé qui a
pu revenir parce que c'est assez rare
donc c'est possible mais après Serena
Williams elle l'avait pas de problème
financiers
à ça c'est que elle peut se payer si je
puis dire le luxe de faire un enfant et
de revenir elle sera pas gênée aux en
tournure dans de sport avec un peu moins
de moyens c'est un petit peu plus
mais c'est très vrai
parce que les revenus d'une sportive et
c'est le cas d'ailleurs Naomi Osaka
c'est ce qu'elle fait en ce moment elle
quelque part elle travaille plus mais ça
aussi on parlait d'anticipation on peut
aussi anticiper le fait d'avoir un
enfant quand même ça peut se préparer
sans anticiper donc effectivement quand
on a ce projet ce plus beau projet au
monde de faire un bébé c'est sûr que ça
un impact sur sur sa vie sportive et
cette navigatrice il est évident qu'à
partir du moment où à moins que ce soit
un bébé action tellement à qu'elle
décide de le garder bon sans doute
c'était peut-être un choix elle sait
très bien que derrière il y aura des
effets des conséquences donc là aussi il
faut il faut l'intégrer et là on a
encore le nouveau problème enfin un
problème supplémentaire c'est celui du
revenu des sportifs qui n'est pas du
tout équivalent à celui des sportifs et
là aussi on sent bien que qu'il y a un
souci et qu'à un moment donné il va
falloir revoir tout ça et nous mettre
sur même pied d'égalité on est
d'ailleurs en train de discuter de ça au
niveau de la loi vous savez que les
revenus en général pour les femmes sont
30 % moins importants que ceux des
hommes oui donc je crois que on retrouve
le même phénomène dans le monde
sportifs aujourd'hui on peut pas
considérer une athlète comme une
je sais pas dire une travailleuse lambda
mais disons qu'une concrètement une
handbaleuse ne fait pas le même métier
que quelqu'un qui travaillerait je sais
pas au contrôle de gestion quelque chose
comme ça elle ne peut pas poursuivre son
activité jusqu'à un mois avoir 15 jours
voir une semaine pour comme certaines
merdes le font et puis ce que disait
tout à l'heure Florian c'est que il y a
le fait de faire un vampire aussi après
il s'en occupait c'est-à-dire qu'il
fonctionne seulement un soutien
financier mais un soutien logistique il
vous parlez de tennis tout à l'heure
être joueuse de aujourd'hui ça veut dire
évidemment aussi donner la planète et
comment on fait pour garder l'enfant
quel solution il y a quand on n'est pas
dans les tous premiers mondiaux et on
peut pas avoir une nounou à domicile
enfin à demeure pendant toute l'année
alors on parle de cette spécificité des
des femmes la spécifique spécificité
pardon des sportifs en général il y a un
autre point d'ailleurs où leur
fonctionnement de carrière n'est pas
tout à fait classique c'est la retraite
il est beaucoup de questions de retraite
en ce moment et une femme s'inquiète
pour les sportifs enfin surtout pour
l'un d'entre eux écoutez je m'interroge
moi que va faire Mbappe après 50 ans
et que va-t-il faire je sais pas si je
sais pas si je ne sais pas si je ne sais
pas si Emmanuel Macron au moment où il
faisait des papouilles à Mbappe lui a
parlé de sa carrière et de sa carrière
quand il serait Seigneur et en
l'occurrence oui la carrière des
sportifs et les vieillissement des
sportifs est un sujet au-delà de la
plaisanterie il est un réel sujet
Comment on réinsère les personnes qui
par ailleurs on décore qui parfois sont
abîmés blessés par une pratique sportive
intensive que fait-on de ces sportifs
seniors et bah c'est un sujet alors je
tiens à rassurer Sandrine Rousseau je
pense que s'il y a bien un athlète en
France qui ne n'a pas de souci à se
faire pour son avenir sa retraite et ses
arrières arrières arrières
petits-enfants c'est bien qu'il ait donc
l'exemple était pas forcément bien
choisi j'ai bien compris la référence à
la blague mais c'est une vraie question
la retraite des sportifs la reconversion
des sportifs Philippe quelque part vous
en êtes un exemple vous avez une
reconversion réussie mais c'est une
question transpose c'est une vraie
question et surtout c'est difficile de
faire que tous les acteurs travaillent
dans le même sens parce que les intérêts
sont pas alignés un club qui met des
moyennes importantes sur un contrat de
joueurs sa seule volonté c'est qu'il
soit performant le week-end et que le
peu de temps libre qu'il est il soit
focalisé sur la récupération et on
considère faire des études pour la
précarité
de savoir si dans l'équilibre
psychologique que le joueur est un
double projet est-ce que mentalement ça
le serre pour qu'il soit meilleur on n'y
a pas répondu chacun a sa croyance moi
je pense que c'est important dans les
sports intermédiaires comme le rugby le
rugby c'est un bon exemple parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des niveaux de
salaire moyen à 25 30000 euros par mois
donc à ces niveaux de salaire là on perd
le contact avec le réel n'est plus dans
la vraie vie et donc on vit quand même
une partie de sa vie d'adulte hors des
réalités et donc c'est encore plus
brutal et finalement il y a des sports
beaucoup plus modestes
dans lesquels moins difficile parce que
le passage le passage est moins et moins
difficile mais en tous les cas c'est une
vraie question et c'est une question qui
se pose sur l'accompagnement
psychologique de la préparation mais
encore une fois pour que toutes les
planètes soient alignées il faut que
tout le monde ait une volonté commune de
croire que ça sert le sportif d'avoir un
fil rouge pendant sa carrière le sujet
de la reconversion Catherine malretti
vous vous y pensiez déjà en tant
qu'athlète il fallait penser à après
j'ai toujours eu de vie en même temps
parce que je faisais mes études
[Rires]
je me préparais à être professeur
d'histoire-géographie parce que je
savais et nous c'est un sport le karaté
ce n'est pas un sport comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure où on a des on touche
des sommes faramineuses de toute façon
il fallait préparer sa sortie et je sais
que pour des collègues qui étaient avec
moi en équipe de France ça a été
extrêmement compliqué parce que en plus
les femmes avaient des tout petits
revenus et pour elle savoir ce que les
allaient faire ensuite ça a été
extrêmement difficile donc effectivement
vous là en ce moment vous n'êtes pas
inquiète pour Kylian Mbappé pour savoir
en fait non je crois personnellement
je pense que je pourrais faire un peu de
consulting
la retraite dont parle Sandrine Rousseau
c'est d'ailleurs très intéressant mais
c'est pas une c'est une retraite qui
arrive très jeune les corps sont certes
abîmés mais ils sont pas abîmés comme
des gens qui ont travaillé 40 ans c'est
la question de la retraite et elle est
plus liée à la reconversion tout à fait
oui oui évidemment mais c'est là où la
problématique aussi du sportif à
l'entrejeu c'est que un sportif plus il
va être performant et bon plus il aura
de chance derrière d'avoir des débouchés
notamment dans son métier les
consultants les entraîneurs les gens qui
sont dans des staffs sont des gens qui
généralement quand même un très grand
niveau donc si on se dit je vais pas
être un peu moins bon mais pas plus
consacré de temps à un projet d'après et
moi mon sport on perd cette possibilité
de performer au maximum donc il y a un
peu une forme de cercle vicieux quelque
part il faut il faut faire un choix
c'est pas évident en fait à déterminer
puisqu'on parle des retraites la
question des revenus de la précarière et
notamment pour les sports qui sont un
petit peu plus confidentiels enfin qui
sont pas exposés médiatiquement et puis
il y a aussi et on découvre quand même
depuis quelques années que nombre de
sportifs finalement se sont fait parfois
arnaquer à ses propres mots et puis il y
a aussi la question du sens qu'on donne
à la précarié à la parole c'est quand
même beaucoup libérée sur la santé
mentale des sportifs après leur carrière
mais aussi pendant leur carrière et
c'est sûr que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
cette question elle n'est pas résolue
que comment pendant sa carrière on
réfléchit déjà à l'après je pense qu'il
y a une vraie urgence pour pour le coup
chez les sportifs mais au niveau des
fédérations je crois que c'est de mieux
en mieux pris en compte et bien souvent
alors je vois moi au niveau de la
Fédération Française de Karaté il y a un
suivi de la tête et on le prépare à
justement quelque chose après la période
de compétition la Fédération Française
de Natation notamment dans les la
génération un petit peu après Laure
Manaudou c'était un des mantras
c'est-à-dire avoir un double projet
préparer l'après carrière mais c'est pas
toujours faisable et il faut quand même
dire que les sportifs quand ils sont en
pleine carrière sont pas toujours prêts
à l'entendre en fait on va passer au
deuxième thème de cette émission de
sport etc nous sommes à six mois de la
Coupe du monde de rugby en France on va
parler de la dangerosité de ce sport
c'est la prolongation de sport etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je le disais la dangerosité la
question de la dangerosité du rugby se
pose mais avant de nous intéresser à
cette cette question fondamentale
j'aurais voulu qu'on fasse le point
peut-être avec vous Philips pangaro sur
la situation à la Fédération française
de rugby parce que on s'était laissé
lors de la dernière émission avec
Bernard Laporte encore président de la
Fédération il ne l'est plus
non ils ne l'est plus on est sur une
question là aussi
éthique au temps que de droit puisque on
a quand même le sujet dans la majorité
des fédérations en ce moment enfin les
majeurs malheureusement la réalité elle
est très simple c'est que donc Bernard
Laporte d'abord c'est mis en retrait et
a proposé une solution
de représentation par un président
délégué et on a demandé au club amateur
de voter pour ou contre ce candidat
proposé Patrick Bisson donc en disant
que si le nom l'emportait il considérait
que c'est un non pas aux candidat mais à
la proposition en elle-même et à la
gouvernance actuelle et donc sur la base
de cette promesse les clubs se sont
beaucoup mobilisés plus de 90% des
votants le nom l'a emporter et à ce
moment là il y a eu une volte-face de du
comité directeur en place qui a dit non
mais finalement on va s'abriter derrière
notre article des statuts qui nous
permet de rester en place donc il y a
une vraie question
vraiment bien en place au rugby comme au
foot
c'est vraiment une une vraie
problématique qu'on vit dans le rugby en
ce moment c'est incapacité de prendre
conscience de ses responsabilités parce
que ces gens-là ils sont acteurs sur le
terrain dans les ligues les comités et
qu'elle croyance il y aura du rugby de
terrain on ces gens-là dans le futur
enfin tout ça et rompu donc on peut
s'abriter derrière les textes tant qu'on
veut mais ça amène une question qui est
vrai dans la société mais pour moi qui
est encore plus prégnante dans le sport
à quel niveau on place l'éthique il
devrait même pas y avoir de débat sur
les sujets qui nous concernent là pour
le rugby ou pour le foot parce que
aujourd'hui on parle des valeurs du
sport alors je précise justement vous
parliez d'éthique je précise que vous
êtes proche de la de la liste grille que
l'on appelle la historique la liste
concurrente récemment
par l'actualité qui m'a donné envie de
m'impliquer pour essayer de de faire
prendre conscience à cette gouvernance
il y avait des enjeux importants le
nouveau président par intérim et
l'ancien président de Lavaur dans le
Tarn Alexandre Martinez donc la suite au
prochain numéro de sport etc je pense
que il est urgent d'attendre on parle
toujours de l'exemplarité des sportifs
on les bassine avec ça ce serait bien
aussi qu'il y a une exemplarité des
dirigeants en fait c'est pas réservé aux
gens se pose cette semaine l'audit
commandité par la ministre améliaud Béa
Castéra a été remis justement ministère
et une conférence de presse de la
ministre la situation est visiblement
difficile à maintenir pour Noël le Great
là encore on attend une décision lors du
prochain comité de direction du prochain
Comex de la Fédération française de
football qui devait avoir lieu hier et
qui aura lieu prochainement là aussi on
va attendre et on se donnera rendez-vous
dans le prochain numéro de sport etc on
aura peut-être un nouveau président de
la Fédération Française de Rugby et un
nouveau président de la Fédération
française de football on va s'intéresser
à la dangerosité du rugby un groupe de
joueurs de rugby a déposé en novembre
dernier un recours en justice contre les
instances du rugby français pour
manquement à leur obligation de sécurité
et d'information c'est la même chose
d'ailleurs de la part de l'ancien joueur
Alexandre la penderie qui lui porte
également plainte contre son club
clairement là c'est une plainte dans le
dans le même registre mis en danger de
la vie d'autrui et blessures
involontaire
de quoi s'agit-il vraiment quand on
parle de commotion cérébrale on va
essayer d'être le plus précis possible
la réponse à cette question nous est
apportée par un médecin spécialiste dans
ce document de notre partenaire looper
le cerveau c'est un organe mou qui est
contenu par une boîte rigide un peu
comme de la gélatine dans une boîte en
fer ou la secouée puis quand vous ouvrez
la botte en fer la gélatine s'est
fendiée
le cerveau c'est un peu pareil dans le
rugby c'est passé quoi avec le
professionnelisme on a augmenté les
gabarits autrefois 1m80 c'était 80 85 kg
aujourd'hui un mètre 80 c'est 100 kg
comme ils sont très musclés ils sont
protégés par cette musculature mais il y
a des organes eux qui ne sont pas mieux
protégés la tête en particulier il y a
pas de muscle autour du crâne donc le
cerveau subit des forces d'accélération
de décélération de plus en plus
importante du fait de la puissance de
l'ensemble du corps subit une onde de
chocs il se déplace à l'intérieur de la
boîte rigide et cette onde de choc
déclenche toutes sortes de réactions à
l'intérieur du cerveau dérèglement des
potentiels d'action entre les membranes
une sécrétion de protéines anormales qui
ressemble beaucoup à la protéine dont on
parle dans la réalité d'Alzheimer qui
est une démence
Philips pangaro est-ce que le monde du
rugby dans le déni face à ce problème
alors je crois que les choses bougent
grâce à ces démarches de joueurs parce
que aujourd'hui les instances sont
compris qu'elles avaient une
responsabilité pénale
je suis assez malheureux qu'on était
obligé d'en arriver jusque-là parce que
moi j'étais en amont dans le fait
d'attirer des enfants à la pratique de
rassurer les parents sur sur le fait que
c'est un sport sûr
j'aurais aimé que comprenne le sujet à
bras le corps avant ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie volonté des
moyennes d'analyser le suivi des joueurs
alors c'est en train de se faire
vraiment au niveau professionnel les
choses se mettent en place mais c'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui dans le rugby
amateur et on a ce phénomène de
commotion aussi dans le rugby amateur
qu'on a du mal à mesurer il y a une
vraie question a priori médical sur à
quel moment il y a d'un point de vue de
diagnostic commotion ou pas commotion
donc il y a déjà une question par
rapport à ça et ça il faut que ce soit
réglé et que derrière on soit très
strict sur les temps de repos que
doivent ivent observer les joueurs après
une commotion et donc là on revient au
problème
le World rugby a imposé maintenant un
repos complet de 7 à 12 jours alors je
vais peut-être Rahir mon âge en disant
ça mais il me semble qu'il y a une
période c'était trois semaines de repos
complet alors les règles ont beaucoup
changé encore une fois il y a un vrai
sujet sur ces protocoles commotions
comment seront le joueur quel est le
diagnostic du médecin à ce moment-là en
tous les cas pour moi on est très loin
du compte en termes de durée il faut
qu'on aille beaucoup plus loin par
rapport à ça parce qu'il en va de de la
survie de notre sport parce que si
aujourd'hui les cas de démence comme on
entend parler ici ce multiplie et il y
en a quand même de façon factuelle de
plus en plus on va avoir un vrai
problème sur des études il y en a qui
sont faites je pense notamment à une
étude britannique qui a été réalisée en
2021 50% des joueurs de rugby de haut
niveau présente une modification
inattendue de leur volume cérébral en
raison d'impact reçu à la tête au cours
de leur carrière 50% c'est toujours
pareil les effets se font souvent sentir
à retardement et je pense qu'on verra
aujourd'hui la mutation du rugby à
laquelle on assiste depuis une dizaine
une quinzaine d'années je pense qu'on en
verra les effets beaucoup plus tard on
mais c'est vrai que les enjeux sont
énormes on parlait tout à l'heure du
monde amateur et des joueuse aussi qu'il
faut pas oublier le professeur Sherman
qui est vraiment la référence sur le
sujet a fait évidemment plusieurs études
et il y en a une que je trouve
particulièrement particulièrement
alarmante parce qu'elle montre que les
femmes sont beaucoup beaucoup plus
vulnérables que les hommes elles mettent
en gros je crois que c'est 40 jours pour
récupérer là où un homme mais à peu près
deux semaines voilà donc cet objet que
j'ai dans les mains de toute façon je
suis pas un ridicule près est-ce que cet
objet peut protéger vraiment oui je vous
remercie franchement personnellement je
prendrai pas mon scooter avec ça enfin
ça me semble quand même plus léger
utile et encore une fois est-ce qu'il y
a des études
alors
ma connaissance qui qui peuvent dire
à quel niveau on place l'efficacité du
casque je crois pas et puis au-delà de
ça je pense que c'est un casque un
casque la violence
la force cinétique je sais pas si on
peut appeler ça comme ça mais elle
vienne jusqu'au cerveau mais elle arrive
de partout aujourd'hui il y a pas que la
tête qui peut être protégée donc on a
aujourd'hui des troubles cérébraux sur
des chaos pas quand il y a juste contact
à la tête il y a eu une situation de jeu
particulière contre l'Irlande du pilier
français uni Antonio a été suspendu
trois semaines pour un plaquage à
l'épaule avec son épaule il vient
heurter le le bas du visage du du joueur
adverse le casque changerait à la
situation de jeu et malheureusement dans
beaucoup de cas de commotion c'est pas
un contact frontal à la tête donc on
réglera malheureusement pas le sujet
avec ça et je pense pas que le pour
revenir à votre question que le rugby
soit dans le déni je pense qu'il y a
quand même une prise de conscience parce
que s'il y a un vrai protocole qui qui
existent alors qui sans doute abendables
et sur lequel on peut progresser mais si
le rugby est dans le déni le foot vit
dans une autre galaxie parce que tous
les week-ends
en Grande-Bretagne il y a eu des vraies
études
on a plus le droit de faire un
entraînement de votre tête en Angleterre
pareil et il y a des vraies études qui
ont été menées là-dessus vous inquiétez
donc on demande aux enfants de plus
jouer au rugby il faut mieux les
protéger bon je pense que au niveau du
karaté nous on a eu les mêmes soucis à
un moment donné et nous et bien
aujourd'hui et bien la tête est protégée
les points sont protégés les pieds sont
sont protégés de telle façon que les
chocs façon la tête est interdite au
niveau du karaté mais faire en sorte que
les chocs soient le moins violents
possible et je pense que on avait
effectivement dans la plupart des sports
mis en place des protocoles qui sont
relativement strictes aujourd'hui mais
peut-être renforcer effectivement les
protections et surtout au niveau des
enfants c'est vrai que sur les sports
américains par exemple il y a une
tradition de la protection soit hockey
sur glace ou le football américain voilà
ils sont bardés de protection ça empêche
pas les blessures et les commotions
enfin ça pour protège quand même pas mal
c'est vrai que nous en Europe on a pas
cette tradition là ce qui est peut-être
un jour il faudra jouer au rugby avec
des armatures de partout peut-être mais
la santé quand même il faut la préserver
je me tourne vers celui qui jouait
aujourd'hui on constate quoi que
finalement ce qui s'est passé dans le
football américain arrive un peu ici
avec ces plinthes collectives ça c'est
beaucoup vu dans le foot US et puis la
durée la durée moyenne de vie sportive
des athlètes parce qu'aujourd'hui on se
rend compte que dans le foot US elle est
extrêmement limitée c'est moins de 5 ans
de durée de vie au très haut niveau
aujourd'hui on est quasiment au double
dans le rugby donc il y a une vraie
question à se poser sur l'activité je
préfère préciser
mais là
et il y a ce sujet là qui se pose c'est
à dire sur les sports aussi sollicitants
et dangereux physiquement combien de
temps l'organisme peut l'accepter sans
trop de troubles et on fait quoi du
rugby scolaire parce que il y a eu une
interruption c'était un mois des
compétitions de rugby organisées par
l'Union nationale du sport scolaire
Suite à un jeune homme de 17 ans qui est
devenu très très tétraplégique après un
mauvais plaquage pendant un match entre
deux lycée donc on arrête le sport le
rugby scolaire non on n'arrête pas où on
aménage les règles parce que si je me
trompe pas pendant cette période je sais
pas si toutes les compétitions sont
arrêtées mais en tout cas on a on a on a
dû reprendre avec ce qu'on appelle le
rugby touché donc est-ce que c'est vers
ça qu'il faut s'orienter pendant une
certaine période le temps que le le
corps se renforce parce que ce qui est
effectivement de la prévention aussi
qu'on peut faire on parlait tout à
l'heure des joueuses de rugby qui sont
pas égales de devant les devant les
chocs et ça tient notamment à leur
musculature en fait leur cou est
beaucoup moins musclé et j'écoutais
l'autre Servat à 15 qui est le monsieur
mêlé du XV de France qui expliquait que
voilà un des billets pour éviter que les
joueurs subissent ces chocs c'est de
énormément renforcer le le musculature
du coup et des cervicales mais au niveau
des d'un enfant renforcer la musculature
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué et
d'autant plus que les blessures et les
chocs chez les enfants se résorbent
moins bien que que pour les adultes donc
aussi bien dans le rugby que dans le
foot je crois que aller vers des
protections plus importantes me semble
me semblerait être l'idéal donc au
minimum le casque pour les enfants pour
jouer au rugby dernier thème à présent
de ce sport etc un an après le
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine et
l'exclusion des sportifs russes des
compétitions olympiques la question se
pose de leur réintégration pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 verra-t-on les
athlètes russes à Paris c'est la
confrontation de sport etc
alors la question c'est poser très
clairement le 25 janvier dernier quand
le Comité olympique international a
dévoyé à dévoiler une feuille de route
en vue de la réintégration des des
sportifs russes et biélorus
réintégration sous bannière neutre donc
avant que je vous demande vos avis
respectifs on va écouter la vie du
président de la vie qui compte la vie du
président ukrainien
ski
les principes olympiques sont détruits
et que les athlètes russes sont
autorisés à participer à des
compétitions ou aux Jeux Olympiques ce
n'est qu'une question de temps avant que
l'État terroriste les oblige à jouer le
jeu de la propagande de guerre
les représentants de l'État terroriste
n'ont pas leur place dans les sports et
les compétitions olympiques
et cela ne peut être couvert par une
prétendue neutralité ou un drapeau blanc
le président ukrainien s'exprimait dans
une réunion des ministres des sports que
vous avez pu voir tous réunis à l'écran
est-ce qu'on accueille des athlètes
russes à Paris pour les Jeux Olympiques
de 2024 alors très sincèrement et
personnellement je pense qu'on ne peut
pas mélanger politique et sport ces
sportifs se sont préparés je sais ce que
je sais ce que c'est de se préparer pour
pour des compétitions et surtout à ce
niveau là et je trouverai ça extrêmement
dommage qu'on les empêche de devenir
participer je crois que ce sont deux
choses qu'il faut absolument
séparées ces gens-là ne sont pas
concernés parce qu'il se passe ils ne
sont pas à l'origine de de cette guerre
et donc voilà je crois qu'il faut
laisser le sport en dehors de tout ça et
permettre à chacun de venir et c'est un
point de vue de sportif que qui rejoint
celui de Martin Fourcade qui est membre
du CIO et président de la commission des
athlètes de Paris 2024 qui lui se dit
favorable à cette réintégration tout en
précisant qu'il soutient le peuple
ukrainien c'est un peu plus difficile
qu'une qu'une question de choix par le
pays haute c'est une question déjà je
pense de choix personnel je pense qu'il
y a des athlètes qui voudront y aller et
d'autres ne voudront pas y aller parce
que peut-être ils estiment que leur pays
dans son bon droit et sur une façon de
le manifester je pense que c'est dota un
choix personnel et certainement pas une
directive et puis encore une fois il
faut pas non plus dans une hypocrisie on
interdit à des athlètes d'aller faire
une compétition mais par contre on
organise des compétitions dans des pays
qui sont pas forcément très nobles quand
on va faire des JO en Chine alors qu'on
connaît les problématiques de droits de
l'homme là on se pose pas la question
des athlètes donc voilà il faut encore
une fois je trouve qu'on fait souvent
peser beaucoup de choses sur les épaules
des sportifs et il faut les laisser un
petit peu tranquille c'est pas leur
niveau que ça se base décidé
c'est des choix personnels et on a tous
un avis différent j'imagine et je pense
que c'est pareil pour les athlètes en
même temps moi je trouve que deux fêtes
c'est impossible de séparer ce sport et
politique si on accueille les athlètes
russes et myélorus à Paris en 2024 il
faut pas se leurrer tout le monde le
sait la Russie va sauter sur l'occasion
pour
évidemment quand c'est conseil un autre
enfin quand ils étaient sous bannières
neutre au jeu de Tokyo en 2021 ils ont
réussi quand même le Comité olympique
russe qu'il fallait pas dire la Russie
avait négocié avec le CIO pour qu'il
puisse avoir des survêtements bleu blanc
rouge et ils ont ils ont saisi toutes
les failles du de l'accord pour mettre
en avant leur signe donc ils vont ils
vont saisir encore une fois ce moment
pour en faire un moment de de fierté
patriotique donc je pense que si on
décide d'être d'accueillir les athlètes
russes il faut être prêt à ça il faut
l'assumer sachant il faut le rappeler
quand même que le dernier mot revient au
CIO
reviendra toute façon
elle était favorable au retour des
athlètes russes et biélorusses désormais
elle est oui elle a changé d'avis elle
est désormais fermement opposée à cette
participation des athlètes russes je
rappelle que des interdictions comme ça
il y en a eu beaucoup dans dans
l'histoire je vais pas remonter jusqu'à
Sparte dans les années 420 avant
Jésus-Christ et pourtant c'est vrai ils
se partagent avaient été exclu mais dans
les dernières exclusions il y a la
Yougoslavie en 92 pas de pas d'athlètes
yougoslave pas d'athlètes d'Afrique du
Sud pendant l'apartheid pendant toute la
période 64 88 c'est une question
difficile pour un athlète
oui mais pour moi encore une fois ça
pose pas au niveau de l'athlète et moi
je reste persuadé que sur ce type
d'événement c'est très difficile de
dissocier sport et politique c'est un
enjeu éminemment géopolitique on a vu en
plus à quel point la Russie en avait
toujours fait un levier une arme
secondaire quand ils ont été exclus les
athlètes russes c'était lié au dopage
aussi on avait on avait vu révéler le
dopage organisé complètement par le
gouvernement russe pour performer donc
là de toute façon on peut s'attendre à
ce qui se passe à peu près le même genre
de choses je crois pas du tout à la
bannière neutre de toute façon tout le
monde saura et les médias seront d'où
sont originaires les sportifs et à la
fois je trouve ça très injuste pour les
sportifs qui se préparent etc mais on ne
peut pas sur le principe de la
préservation des sportifs
remettre ça en perspective avec l'enjeu
qui pour moi est bien supérieur de de
stratégie géopolitique russe à travers
ce genre d'événements et
particulièrement sûr et je rappelle que
certains pays sont opposés à cette
réintégration très vivement opposée
notamment pour la Lettonie l'Estonie et
la Pologne qui menace de boycotter en
cas de présence d'athlètes russes et
très dur pour les athlètes de ces
pays-là qui se retrouvent pris en otage
là
elle est constante cette manipulation
entre guillemets le mot manipulation des
athlètes par les États oui effectivement
il se retrouve toujours un peu un peu au
centre sans être non plus à manœuvre
c'est un peu paradoxal mais il y a en
fait il y a toujours une forme
d'injustice à une sanction en fait
pourquoi on interdire
l'accès aux Jeux olympiques de Paris 204
Horus au biélorus c'est bien pour faire
pression sur le pouvoir russe parce
qu'on sait effectivement l'importance
que le sport a dans la stratégie de
Poutine aussi c'est aussi pour ça donc
s'il y a un moment c'est les athlètes
russes et biélorusses qui devront faire
les frais je pense que certains pays du
monde ils sont prêts effectivement
aujourd'hui il y a tout le monde ne
s'aligne enfin il y a pas uneanimité
chez dans les pays du monde on voit bien
qu'il y a un axe effectivement Pologne
peut-être Grande-Bretagne aussi certains
pays de l'Est Lituanie on Scandinavie
aussi la Norvège et certains et d'autres
pays comme la France qu'on sent un peu
plus gênés aux entreprises
[Musique]
comprendre
juillet voilà on garde espoir que la
guerre soit terminée d'ici là oui il
faudrait le souhaiter mais voilà moi je
reste persuadé que c'est dur pour les
athlètes c'est très dur pour les
athlètes et pour moi je ne pense pas
qu'il faille mêler à la fois aux
athlètes les athlètes français notamment
eux effectivement ils parlent d'athlète
à athlète et ils comprennent pas
effectivement qu'un de leur père qui a
consacré 4 ou 8 ans de sa carrière à un
rêve on soit privé au moment où il
arrive il faut être sportif pour le pour
le comprendre et le sentir
en début d'émission de cette
problématique de maternité qui peut vous
faire louper une compétition et c'est
vrai que un jeux olympiques c'est tous
les quatre ans dans une cas d'athlète
vous allez en faire combien 1 2 3 au
mieux donc vous en prie ouais ça arrive
mais c'est très donc vous en privez pour
des raisons qui ne dépendent pas de vous
c'est très dur c'est très violent
d'autant plus qu'il y a une partie du
peuple russe qui est contre cette guerre
donc voilà
pour moi ça me semble extrêmement
compliqué bon cette question ne sera pas
tranchée ici de toute façon c'est Thomas
bar le président de la du Comité
international olympique qui prendra la
décision donc je ne sais pas s'il y aura
des athlètes russes et biélorus à Paris
une chose est sûre en tout cas c'est
qu'il y aura pas de climatisation dans
le village olympique lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique oblige c'est
Anne Hidalgo la mère de Paris qui nous
explique cette position
on a choisi de faire des jeux écolo vous
savez que pour moi faire ces jeux
c'était ramener bien sûr le regard sur
Paris redonner de l'élan grâce à la
puissance des Jeux Olympiques et par
olympiques mais surtout accélérer la
transformation écologique de la ville le
village olympique n'est pas à Paris il
sera à Saint-Denis sur l'île Saint-Denis
et il est entièrement mais vraiment fait
avec des bâtiments en bois avec une
climatisation naturelle auront le droit
de louer des climatiseurs mobiles
dans le village olympique
la climatisation naturelle vous savez ça
fonctionne très très bien et moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour le confort des
athlètes mais je pense beaucoup plus à
la survie de l'humanité
donc la survie de l'humanité dépense
selon Anne Hidalgo de la présence ou pas
de climatisation dans le village
olympique est-ce que c'est possible de
participer à des jeux olympiques quand
il y a une vague de chaleur comme on en
connaît malheureusement très souvent à
Paris et qui a pas de climatisation dans
le village
d'algo à aller participer peut-être ne
serait-ce qu'à une séance sportive pour
comprendre la situation dans laquelle on
est quand il fait chaud alors je l'ai
vécu pour un championnat du monde au
Mexique et je vous assure qu'avec
l'altitude et la chaleur c'était on perd
la moitié de ses moyens si ce n'est plus
et on voit ça confirmera c'est
extrêmement difficile je veux dire ça
les conditions pour un athlète doivent
être respectées donc là j'ai du mal à
comprendre sa position et ce qu'elle met
en avant les installations sportives
seront climatisées elles
et je crois pas que ce soit prévu en
tout cas pas dans la globalité presque
c'est intéressant comme ce derrière là
un peu la plus entrée à la caricature
qu'on peut en faire parce que bon si les
cinémas offrent effectivement des
conditions sans climatisation de
température acceptable tant mieux mais
je pense que derrière ça il y a une
vraie question c'est en fait à quel
effort le monde du sport est prêt
finalement pour
apporter sa part dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique il y a
forcément un moment où ça va interférer
sur le confort des athlètes voilà c'est
et je pense que ça va être intéressant
d'observer justement dans les mois et
les années à venir comment les
différentes parties vont s'exprimer et
si les sportif à un moment sont prêts à
renoncer à quelque chose on a vu cette
semaine que il y a une centaine de
skieur qu'on lançait un appel à leur
propre fédération pour qu'elle fasse
plus sur ce sur cette question là et
modifier notamment son calendrier donc
peut-être renonce à certains intérêts
commerciaux donc voilà j'ai encore une
fois je pense qu'effectivement ce que
l'exemple choisi et la façon dont c'est
formulé est peut-être un peu excessif
mais ça pose quand même une question
derrière parce si on considère la
production d'électricité en France qui
est très largement décarbonée est-ce que
est-ce qu'on est vraiment sûr que la
climatisation aura un impact sur le
réchauffement climatique c'est peut-être
une question posée à des climatologues
puisque si en coupant la clim pendant un
mois on sauve la planète pourquoi pas
envisageons le mais pareil il faut il
faut prendre ça une échelle globale ça
me paraît quand même purement plutôt une
mesure gadget symbolique qui n'a aucune
incidence est-ce que les athlètes
pourront laver leur maillot pendant la
compétition parce que ça consomme de
l'eau
sèches on en parlait enfin non mais
évidemment que c'est on peut pas rigoler
trop avec ça c'est une vraie question
mais il faut il prend une question il y
a une question en dessous qui se pose
c'est qu'il y a des fédérations qui vont
qui sont extrêmement riches et qui donc
vont décider de d'enlever leurs athlètes
du village olympique et de les installer
dans des hôtels climatisés et donc c'est
encore les fédérations
ultra-riches qui vont avoir les moyens
de de mettre leurs athlètes dans les
meilleures conditions et les
fédérations plus petites qui en tout cas
moins fortunées peut-être que ce sera
encore le cas sachant que les athlètes
qui vivent en dehors du village
olympique je dirais pas que c'est vieux
comme les jeux mais ça fait très
longtemps que ça existe mais pourtant il
nous parle tous du village olympique et
de l'ambiance dans le village olympique
oui sans les basketteurs des Américains
n'ont jamais logé
et alors visiblement il commenceront pas
à Paris 2024 de ce que j'ai compris ils
ont pas l'intention non plus de derrière
derrière cette question de la
climatisation il y a beaucoup de
questions qui se posent évidemment avant
ces Jeux Olympiques qu'on attend avec
impatience il y a quand même une
question qui fâche Catherine belrity et
je sais pas comment vous avez pris le
fait que le karaté ne soit pas au
programme des Jeux de Paris 2024 ça
empêchera la France et Steven Da Costa
de défendre son titre olympique et oui
malheureusement alors
tout à fait
nous sommes battus pendant des années
pour pouvoir entrer dans ces jeux
olympiques la Fédération française c'est
quand même 250 000 licenciés on a des
athlètes de haut niveau qui qui aurait
pu nous faire des médailles et là on
fait une médaille et on nous dit et bien
prochain Jeux Olympiques vous ne serez
pas présent c'est voilà donc on est on a
essayé d'intervenir à plusieurs reprises
pour faire revenir sur la décision mais
la décision a été prise et
malheureusement pour pour Steven qui est
un athlète merveilleux qui aurait pu
justement remporter quelques titres
olympique et d'autres athlètes de la
fédération et bien de voilà on se sent
pénalisés on se sent triste la question
étrangée vous avez formé tous les
journalistes de l'équipe au breakdance
ceci dit évidemment on avait aussi la
possibilité d'en avoir en karaté mais le
breakdance au-delà de la façon dont je
le dis peut-être en souriant c'est
quelque chose qui est nouveau pour sans
doute beaucoup d'entre nous peut-être
une question de génération là aussi le
skate
et tous les journalistes de l'équipe de
ne sont pas encore formés au breakdance
mais qui l'a déjà qui
[Rires]
il y en a bien sûr qui qui suivent ça
déjà depuis plusieurs années et qui vont
le faire de façon plus intense ces
prochains mois on a déjà commencé à
faire des déplacements rencontrer des
sportifs on les a suivi à New York il y
a pas longtemps donc mais moi je trouve
ça bien justement en tant que
journaliste enfin suivi du sport de
s'éveiller à d'autres disciplines mais
même si effectivement ça suivre une
autre discipline enfin le fait qu'une
nouvelle discipline apparaisse ça veut
dire qu'elle a d'autres qui
disparaissent parce que le break mais
c'est du vrai sport parce que on rigole
parce que c'est de la musique etc on
fait le patinage artistique il y a de la
musique c'est du sport le breakdance
c'est vraiment du sport pour avoir
essayé je vous invite à essayer le
breakdance c'est ultra sport soit du
sport mais je veux dire au niveau de
l'organisation voilà c'est un sport qui
était très peu connu alors que là on a
une grosse fédération au niveau du
karaté et on a quand même du mal à
comprendre qu'on sorte une fédération
comme celle-là qui est extrêmement
importante qui représente quand même je
ne sais combien de pays et 10 millions
de pratiquants dans le monde je veux
dire un moment donné c'est surprenant
qu'on sorte une grosse fédération pour
mettre quelque chose qui est à peine
construit c'est surprenant sur les
complètement c'est aussi que le CIO veut
parler à des générations peut-être un
petit peu plus jeunes voilà des sports
qui sont un peu plus dans la rue et moi
dans les salles donc c'est pas si
étonnant je pense on parlez de
breakdance et Tik Tok vous êtes vous
avez essayé Florent magasin Tik Tok et
breakdance ensemble vu que c'était
blessé à la main c'est peut-être j'ai
essayé de tourner sur la tête et en fait
ça a complètement perdu
[Musique]
la question de ces nouveaux sports qui
rentrent c'est quelque chose qui est
amusant quand on le regarde de
l'extérieur en tant que
je trouve ça stratégie parce que moi
j'ai ma casquette de d'agence de
marketing dans le sport parce que un
vrai enjeu de rajeunissement des
audiences aujourd'hui on sait que les
marques vont sur ces réseaux sociaux et
peut-être que il y a plus de stars qui
ont des followers en breakdance et qui
rend aller chercher cette audience là
que le karaté en faisant fille des
chiffres etc donc je pense qu'on est
aussi dans cette réflexion là d'aller
chercher des sports qui sont capables
d'attirer cette nouvelle cible et
peut-être derrière tout ça des nouveaux
sponsors qui qui ont vraiment besoin de
façon plus importante de toucher cette
génération là donc on va s'ouvrir à ça
je trouve ça assez injuste aussi par
rapport au nombre de personnes que ça
pénalise mais je trouve ça je trouve ça
et et un champion olympique mais je
trouve ça assez logique dans le la
nécessité d'ouverture du CIO j'étais
tout à fait d'accord qu'on l'ouvre de
nouveau sport mais qu'on fasse entrer
mais j'ai bien compris en tout cas il
fallait pas sortir le karaté peut-être
éventuellement le tir au pistolet ça
c'était moins grave il y a d'autres
sports on se dit bon éventuellement il
nous manquerons moins quoi mais c'est
vrai en plus le karaté c'est
incompréhensible parce que c'est les
arts martiaux
le MMA enfin voilà les sports de course
comme quelque chose qui plaît plus de
défense avant tout pardon enfin bon
voilà en tout cas ça parle je pense plus
aux jeunes que le sport de défense ou le
concours complet quoi oui ça bon mais
ton pied alors on aura pas de on aura
pas de karaté et on est on sera
évidemment à fond derrière nos athlètes
du skate et du breakdance dans ces jeux
olympiques 2024 merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à cette émission avec
autant d'enthousiasme merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis un grand merci à
l'équipe éditoriale et technique qui
m'aident à préparer cette émission nous
nous retrouvons le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro de sport etc
[Musique]